Hello world,
it's Saroj and stock price prediction.
How can we use AI to predict stock prices?
And this is the part of the Ai for
business series that I'm doing.
And what you're seeing behind me is a
demo of using AI to predict stock prices.
So this is actually a game.
What I'm doing is I'm competing against
an AI to see who can make better buys
and sells.
And this is a simulated markets.
So I'm going to say I'm going to
buy some stock right here. Okay,
so you see this dark blue, um, the AI
already beat me so I can start over again.
But the idea in this simulation is that
the AI and I will both be buying and
selling stocks and we're going to
see who can make the better buy,
sell orders in this simulated environment.
So it's going to start like this.
I can speed it up,
I can slow it down and I'm going to say,
I'm going to buy a stock right here and
then notice that the stock is bought.
It's going to go up and
down and up and down.
I can speed up the timeline
and I'm going to say, okay,
let's wait for it to go
up. Oh, time to sell. Okay,
so I sold it there and now the
AI is doing the same thing.
I'm going to buy it here and then I'm
going to try to sell it higher than I
bought it, right? That's the
point. Come on. There we go.
So I made a little kind of,
well, not really some kind of profit,
but the AI is going to do the same.
We're going to see who has better.
So that's the AI buying right there
and it's going to learn over time.
So this is the demo that
we're going to build today.
It's using the linear regression model.
But in this video we're going to go
over several different types of AI
applications. When it comes to finance,
it's not just about stock prediction.
Ai can be used immensely
in the field of Fintech.
And we're going to talk about how we're
going to talk about who is doing this.
We're going to talk about everything. So
sit down and get ready for this. So how,
how do we start here?
What do we talk about first?
What we know that the finance industry
in general has been an early pioneer of
AI technologies since the 70s.
Wall Street has been using predictive
models to try to predict the prices of the
market, right? How is, what trend,
what direction is the market moving in?
How can these hedge funds best
allocate their funds such that they are
optimizing how much money they're
earning at any given point, right?
There's so many different data points
out there on the web and these techniques
are very closely guarded as secrets.
They don't want us to know how
they're doing things, right?
That's their trade secret. Why
would they open source that? That's,
that's their value. That's, that's how
they make money. But to me, I don't care.
Like I'm making enough money
from Youtube ads and you know,
partnerships and et cetera. So I don't
care. I just want you guys to, you know,
make, make that money. So just listen up
for, you know, all the different ways.
I'm going to tell you how it's done.
So there's so many different data points
out there. Rights, there's tweets,
there's reddit posts, there's in
general sentiment analysis, right?
From news headlines from
people, consumers, businesses.
How are they feeling
about a specific stock?
So we can think of that as classification.
At the same time,
we can use all of the
financial Ma Metadata,
think of what's all those financial data
points, dividends that are being sent,
stock prices obviously, but p, and e,
all of these different little financial
metrics, these numerical data points.
How can we use that to perform
a regression analysis as
in time series analysis?
Given these numbers in the past,
what is a number in the future?
And if you think about it,
it's not a single variant problem.
It's a multivariate problem,
but we can graph that out in a line that's
two dimensional for us to view later
on,
and I'll talk about that as well,
but basically what I'm trying to say is
that there are different ways that we
can classify this problem.
It can be a classification problem,
it could be a regression problem there,
different models we can use.
We can use a neural network,
we can use a support vector machine,
we can use linear regression. So
we'll go into that later on. Um,
but Citibank or Citi group estimates
of the biggest banks have doubled the
number of people that they employ
to handle compliance and regulation.
And this is costs the banking
industry billions of dollars,
lots in loss of money.
So this was a very interesting survey
that I found were a bunch of banks were
asked,
uh,
are you considering deploying an
AI solution in the next 18 months?
And the majority said that
they have it on their roadmap,
the majority of the responses
within the next 18 months.
So there is an opportunity here to work
with these bigger fintech companies and
say, Hey, I know you have
this on your roadmap. I have
this great solution. Use It,
try it out and you won't be disappointed.
Right?
So for those of you who want to
start an AI startup in Fintech,
this is a great opportunity.
And 90% of the world's data has been
collected in the past two years.
Never before has this happened. So
the opportunity, the time is now.
If you're going to do
something now is the time.
Because we are in this renaissance of
data and there's so much of it and nobody
has any idea of how what to do with it
or about AI in general or how it works.
So you, if you have some interest
in both AI and in finance,
it's your responsibility to do
something good for people using that.
Make companies more profitable good
companies and give people jobs, right?
You'd be a job creator in this way.
Like what numerous is doing.
They're giving jobs to data
scientists across the world. They're,
they're putting real money into the
pockets of talented developers by
crowdsourcing their hedge fund. That's
one great idea we'll get into later.
But if you're a CFO of a big company,
your job is to figure out in what ways
AI can help increase the efficiency of
your organization. Operational accounting,
financial reporting, allocations,
adjustments, reconciliation's,
intercompany transactions. These,
these are just the few ways that AI
can be used to make your company more
efficient. And then in another
survey where companies were asked,
where do you expect AI to be introduced
in your organization in the next three
years?
Most said risk assessment,
which is a really interesting response
and we'll talk about that and it in
general.
But to really drive my point home,
the market for AI in finance is expected
to grow from 1.3 billion last year to
7.4 billion in 2022 that's
four years from now.
That's a lot. So the
market will grow. Okay, so,
but the problem is that there are
problems with integrating AI rights.
They've got these, these companies have
these legacy technology environments.
It's hard to upgrade. They have
the lack of skills and expertise,
the lack of budgets,
all of these problems that are
pain points for these companies.
They want to grow, they want to,
you know, perform fraud detection.
They want to optimize their budgeting,
they wants to allocate resources most
efficiently to then grow the company.
But they have all these problems.
So if you can tackle,
remember a single niche problem very,
very well,
then you are golden.
They will come to you.
And you will build a brand around this
as I built a brand around AI education.
So you've got to really pick one niche
field and just go in all the way,
right? So there are a lot of problems,
especially data silos, right?
So here's a little map for you to see all
the different ways that AI can be used
in the fintech market,
from credit scoring to personal finance
assistance for millennials. So there's,
there's also opportunity in
the consumer space as well.
Young millennials prefer or not prefer,
but they're more willing to listen
to financial advice from not a human,
but from an AI, right? A Chat Bot, hey,
I see you have this goal for
your budget to be, you know,
saved this much amount in this month.
Here's your bank account,
I see what you're spending,
here's how you can best spend,
here's a good budget for you. And it
can update in real time. Right? Right.
So there are there opportunities
here for consumers as well. So there,
there are startups in this space and
we're going to talk about them as we go.
But one huge use cases,
increasing security rights.
How can these companies increase the
rate of or decrease the rate of false
positive studies that are transactions
that are classified as fraudulent but
they're not really fraudulent. They
just belong to a good person. But this,
the human behind the process misclassified
it and an AI can help reduce that,
right?
So there's,
I mean this causes billions in losses
for retailers and this is a real problem.
And remember any money you
can save these institutions,
they're going to throw money at you,
right? So because they are saving money,
save them money and then you will
make money, right? That's the,
that's the whole idea here. Save these
companies money and you will make money.
So, um, when it comes
to improving security,
mastercard implements what's
called decision intelligence.
So this is just one example of a
fintech company that's using AI to,
for security.
In this case it's fraud detection.
What they're doing is anomaly detection.
Obviously this is closed source,
but I'm going to guess that they're using
some deep autoencoder where they are
trying to detect the anomaly
in a transaction data set.
And that is pick the
needle in the haystack,
that transaction that doesn't
look like all the others.
And do I mean by look like in our case,
right look like it means there are
hundreds of thousands of features. Um,
the time that our user Spence putting
their mouse on one specific corner of the
screen,
the amount that they purchased,
where they're purchasing from data
points we wouldn't even think about, um,
an AI can learn from.
So remember that the consumers
are generating a lot of
data and when it comes to
the fraudulent transactions,
you can use a network on neural network
or any type of model really that will
perform. Anomaly detection on auto
encoder is a great example of that.
Google or youtube auto encoders
Suraj for a great video on that.
Science is another, a startup
that is focusing on this. Um,
but they're collecting data from over
6,000 websites and then using that in
their fraud detection solution.
Another great example of Ai in Fintech
is reducing processing times, right?
So one example would be receipt
like processing receipts, right?
So one startup that's focused on this,
it's called Paris script.
And what they're doing is
they're using OCR that is object,
optical character recognition technology
to read in receipts and create a data
set from that and easily, you know,
that's just data input, right?
It's a manual human data input that
they're replacing with automation.
Great use case. Another one is
obviously algorithmic trading,
which is a topic of our video today.
Yeah,
well we have some past data set and what
we do is we take this past dataset and
we learn from it so that we can predict
the price of certain companies stock in
the future. And there are lots of hedge
funds that are doing this right now.
Obviously they're very close source
because that's their, you know,
that's their secret,
right?
But what we can do is we can look at
the open source hedge funds out there.
A newer one is new Mariah.
And what new Muray does is they have
built an open sourced hedge fund for data
scientists where you can submit a model
based on some data that they provide and
they will award. And the best data
scientists with some cryptocurrency,
so if your model outperforms
the others you will win.
So that's a great way of imagining
what a good hedge fund looks like.
Obviously there's a lot of room
for improvement here and there,
just one company and you can definitely
make a competitor to new Muray find a
pain point that they don't really focus
on and focus on that since the and
technologies is another one.
What they've done is they
used AI to create a high
frequency trading bot that is
is running trillions of simulated trading
scenarios using public data so they
can squeeze 1800 days of
trading into a few minutes.
That's incredible and that's something
that only a machine, not a human could do
credit lending, right. If you think about
deciding whether or not to give
a person some insurance or alone,
what you are doing is you're
making a prediction, right?
Based on their past data,
where they're from, how much money
they make, their marital status.
These are features.
This is a perfect application for machine
learning and that's what we're just
going to to see over time. Zest.
Finance is one startup that does this,
but there's a lot of room for competition
in the space approved borrow borrowers
that other lenders are missing a,
so check out that link as well.
Portfolio management, right. So this
goes back to what I was talking about,
about helping millennials keep track
of their finances, right? So if you,
if they have a human financial advisor,
that's expensive,
but not everybody has the money for that.
So ideally that they don't need that.
They can use a machine.
The, this could be an APP,
this could be some kind
of chrome extension. Uh,
but what it does is it's a Robo advisor.
We could call it a Robo advisor that
will spread investments across asset
classes and financial instruments in
order to reach the user's goals. Like,
I want to save x amount in the next years.
Okay,
let's see how much money you have. Let's
see what fields you're interested in.
Let me invest in this, this, this, and
this. And then track returns over time.
Use those returns and learn from
them and then just keep investing.
So it's an optimized wealth experience.
Responsive dot. Ai Does this,
but there's a lot, like I said, a lot
of room for competition in this space.
So I just wanted to go over a few examples
of startups that are doing this right
now. And now what we can do is we
can look at some theory, right? So,
so how do we do this, right? Using the
tools that we have at our availability,
we have the python programming language,
we have tensor flow, we have care os,
we have psychic learn. These are
open source machine learning models.
We have datasets available online, uh,
from Quantopian, from Google finance,
from a Kaggle. There was a bunch of
public transaction data sets online.
It's stock data sets online and we have
Twitter. We can scrape the Twitter. Um,
we can scrape Twitter, we can
scrape, read it, we can scrape a CNN,
a bunch of news headlines. But how
do we really learn from this? Right?
That's the real question.
So there's a lot of different
data points that we could use,
but then it comes down to do we want
this to be a regression problem or do we
want it to be a classification problem?
And the answer is we could do it both
ways, right? So one way to think of it as,
as a regression model where we are
only using numerical data, right?
So the simplest way to think
about this is a multi is a,
is a single variable regression
problem, right? So in this image,
what you're seeing is aligned.
The slime called y equals mx plus B,
mx plus B,
which is a slope of a straight line.
And what we can do is we can say,
based on the prices alone,
let's try to predict the
price in the future. Great.
But the problem is that there
are more data points than that.
We could build a simple model like that,
but if we wanted more data points,
we would just add them in as
rose, as rose in a Dataset, right?
Not just prices,
but all these different financial
data points that would be inside of a
financial report, for example. So returns,
dividends, et Cetera, things like that.
So that's one way to think about it. Given
the past data, what's the next point?
Another way to think about this as, as
is as a classification problem, right?
So binary, yes, no buy or right,
the price will go up or it will go
down. And how do we do that? Well,
we can use numerical data as well,
but another way we could do,
we could think about is using
textual data. So sentiment analysis,
we could compile all of these tweets,
we can compile all of these right poets
and then we could say good or bad, right?
Then we can run a sentiment analysis
algorithm on all of those. Uh,
one great one would be a neural
network that's pretrained.
So we can use a pre trained neural
network that's been trained on different
types of texts,
labeled datasets.
So it knows if some Texas is
generally positive or negative,
some great libraries that do this,
right? How do the box are? Um,
um, text blob is one. Text blob is
one, but there are others as well.
But I'm going to get back to you on what
some of those good libraries are. Um,
there we go.
Nltk yes, Nltk is another great
library, but NLTK and text blob.
So we could think of,
think of it as regression.
We could think of it as classification.
And then you might think, well, okay,
what if I want to combine both the
numerical data and the textual data?
How do I do that? Well, what
you can do is you can say, okay,
I'm going to compile a Dataset of, for a
given company, all of the reddit posts,
all of the tweets, all the blog
posts, all of the comments,
everything for a given date.
And I'm going to run sentiment
analysis on all of that.
And it's going to be like, yes,
no, yes, no, yes, no, you know,
good, bad, good, bad, good,
good dad.
And then we can say,
let's take the majority of
those sentiments and say
that the majority is going
to be the overall sentiment for that day.
So let's say the majority are good,
then we can just say,
well for this day,
the sentiment generally for
this stock is good. Yes,
no zero one.
So we then turn that into a numerical
data 0.01 then we could say,
here's what we already
run sentiment analysis.
Let's take that zero or one and add it
to our numerical data set and then we
could classify it as a regression problem,
right?
So we've already run sentiment analysis
and we can take that sentiment data
added as as as a row,
a single row in our numerical data set.
And there we go. Now we have
a regression problem, right?
So that's how we would do that.
So let's think about this.
When it comes to linear regression,
that's the simple equation.
Y equals mx plus B.
I've got a great video on this called
linear regression using gradient descent
Saroj. But anyway we can do is
if we have a single data point,
the price and the dates, we can build a
model around that, the line of best fit,
then we could use that line, plug in a
new date and it's going to output the uh,
price. And that's going to
be either higher or lower.
And we can buy based on that.
And now that this is very easy to do,
we can do this very simply using
the psychic learn library, right?
So we'll load up a data set.
This is a Dataset of Boston house prices,
but this is just for show.
Then we'll say, well,
we want a single feature from the Dataset,
which are the prices for a given date.
We'll split the data into
training and testing.
And once we do that in a single line,
we can build a linear regression model.
Once we have that model, we can then
predict the next price for the next day.
That's the easy way.
So, so that's one way.
Another model we could use is
the support vector machine.
So support vector machines,
same exact concept. We can say,
instead of doing linear regression,
we'll just say support vector
machine just like that.
And so for support vector machines,
we just replaced that single line of
linear regression with the word support
vector machine.
So it's the same library second learn,
but we replaced it with support
vector machine. So remember,
support vector machines can act as both
a regression analysis or as sentiment
analysis for classification either or.
In this case we're talking
about regression then comes
neural networks, right?
We can't have a video on stock prices
without talking about neural networks.
Neural networks. I've been very popular
in recent years, but it's very simple.
If you think about it,
it's the same equation right here.
What we're looking at is the
equation for a simple neural network.
We have some input data.
We give it to this model.
What the model does is essentially
taking every single data points,
multiplying it by input
times a weight matrix,
and then we're going to add a bias value.
That's going to be the output.
We apply a nonlinearity or activation
function to that and it's going to give an
give us an help put yes, no, right up,
down or in the case of regression it can
say what's going to be the next stock
price. So it's, it's, it's very
simple in this case as well. However,
when it comes to neural networks,
the one that has outperformed most others
when it comes to stock price analysis
is the LSTM network. This is the
long short term memory network.
So neural networks can predict
prices that are short term,
but a long short term memory network can
make predictions about sequences far in
the future. And these had been applied
to textual character recognition, um,
modules. They've been applied to
new numbers as well. And so that's,
that's what's really given a lot of,
um,
that's what's given a lot
of progress in this field.
What we can do is we can use the care
Ross deep learning library to do this,
which is built on tensorflow.
And here's an example of that.
We use the same psychic learn
library to load the input data,
and we're using tariffs
to build a simple model.
Now there's one more type of
learning I want to talk about.
And that's reinforcement learning.
So reinforcement learning is all
about learning from trial and error.
And I think that in in the,
in our case,
the best way to really learn from our
input data is to use reinforcement
learning combined with a
supervised learning model.
What I'm talking about is a supervised
and unsupervised learning forecast.
They provide a forecast that predict
future events and reinforcement learning
optimizes future outcomes.
There's a difference, right?
So what we can do is we can say
inside of a simulated environment,
let's run some markets.
But outside of that,
have an agent that's a learning
from multiple simulations.
What to do and what not to
do to reinforcement learning
is all about trial and
error. An agent in an environment,
we'll take old, make an
action, receive a reward,
update itself,
and repeat to try to optimize for that
action to receive that reward, right?
So the best way to do this or the
easiest way is to use the open Ai Jim
Environment,
which makes making reinforcement learning
agents very simple with just a few
lines of code and what we
can do is use the siren,
a open AI reinforcement
learning environment.
This is pulling data directly from the
interactive brokers Api to create an
interface for off the shelf ml algorithms
to trade on real live financial
markets.
Very exciting stuff.
So I definitely recommend checking
that out when it comes to our demo.
Now it's time for our demo.
When it comes to our demo,
what we're really doing is we're just
using a simple linear regression model for
the sake of this demo, but
it's a, it's a package web app.
You can run it directly
from your local machine.
There's a web demo of it as well.
But what I really wanted to do was give
you this kind of skeleton that you can
then just plug and play
your own model very easily.
You don't have to think
about other models, right?
And you can just plug and play your
model right here and it's going to work.
But if we look in the
gets stock data function,
which is the really the interesting part,
what it's doing is it's pulling
that stock data from Quandl,
which is an API for um,
for financial data.
And it's using this API key to pull
that data. And it's right here,
I'll show it to you in a second.
But once it's pulled that data,
this is just based on past stock prices
for a given stock, right? So past prices,
once it's pulled that data, it's
going to format. It's right.
So adjusting price opening, Clive
price, high, low close, et cetera.
Once it's formatted that notice that all
it's doing is it's using psychic learn
to perform a simple linear
regression, right? Input
output. The input is the price.
The outputs is the, is a date, right? So
that's it. Well, the input is the date.
The output is the price.
What's the mapping? Right?
So this is the most simple version of
a stock price prediction algorithm we
could make. But the, the
idea is the same, right?
So if we have that input data,
whether it's one feature,
whether it's 10 features,
whether it's hundred features, we can
always put that into a simple model.
So with these libraries like carrots,
with the psychic learn,
we don't have to build them from scratch.
We don't have to think about all of
those magic numbers, the parameters,
all of these, you know, different
things. We can just say in a single line,
you know, LSTM network. If this was chaos,
we could say support vector machine.
If this is,
if this is a psych,
it learn,
it's always the same thing.
But this is the basic idea here.
If you compile it and run it,
it's going to look like this.
You can compete against an AI.
So the AI in this case a is making
decisions based on the past.
These, these, these data points are all
random and you can compete with them.
So this is just one way to do it.
If you have any kind of conference or
a project or presentation coming up,
definitely feel free to use this web app
as a base templates to then, you know,
just plug and play inside of gets stuck
data. Yes, you could get the stock data,
you can add in more data,
like sentiment analysis from
Twitter Api from the reddit post.
And remember you just add those in as a
single feature in your excel spreadsheet
zero or one.
So then you can run numerical analysis
on what's essentially textual data.
So I hope this video was helpful to you.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos and for now I'm going to predict
the future.
So thanks for watching.